madam chief justice madam deputy chief
these judges at kenya's supreme court
have a difficult decision to make if we
look at the number of the polling
stations they've been hearing a
presidential election case that has been
disputed
president-elect william ruto was
declared winner of last month's poll his
opponent rylo dinger came second
odinga says the election was rigged
at the heart of the case is a role
played by an increasingly divided
electoral commission
four of its commissioners have rejected
the results
the others including the chair of the
commission wafula chabukati
their colleagues of trying to force a
runoff to see them being divided on
an issue that the entire of the
commission
was managing is really surprising and is
very
scary even to some extent because we are
talking about
a country which has nearly gone to war
because of elections this is not the
first time that kenya is going through a
hotly contested judicial process after a
national poll
the presidential election was nullified
in 2017 for the first time in africa
judges said the poll was murdered by
irregularities some kenyans say this
time
the stakes are much higher
opinion outside the courtroom is divided
misinformation is rife and those who are
trying to get a sense of what is
happening say they are overwhelmed
we're looking at twitter on facebook on
whatsapp on instagram tick tock all
these platforms were awash with a lot of
false information and we see this
because the institutions that are
charged with giving kenyans regular
updates or credible information were
taking a step back
a group calling itself the people's
parliament has also been monitoring
what's going on in street corners
but even they say they are polarized
their debates are based on which
political side they support one thing is
clear
we want our courts
to dispense nothing but justice
kama supreme court in under could
nullify if the supreme court is going to
nullify i am telling william ruto we are
ready we shall vote you in again
many kenyans say they just want to know
the truth no matter which way the court
rules
catherine soy al jazeera nairobi